the air crackles with the sound of
gunfire
Ukrainian and Russian troops are
engaging At Close Quarters
the Kremlin claims to have captured the
salt mining town of solidar but holding
it may be another matter
units wait on standby to Medevac troops
armored vehicles rushing along broken
roads attending to the injured
[Music]
as we move closer to the entrance of the
town we found deserted houses and
abandoned animals
both sides have taken serious casualties
under the Relentless barrages of
artillery
very few people have remained in this
area and as we pass destroyed homes the
bombs started falling once again
well there's a lot of
fighting still going on here
we've just
had the sound of a shell Screech
overhead
that's not clear exactly what's going on
inside solidar but it seems that the
ukrainians have been pushed out
and are very much on the outskirts at
the moment but the big concern is for
civilians who are still trapped inside
this terrifying War has destroyed
communities forcing millions of people
from their homes
it's hard to see how they will return to
these places
further back from the front line
soldiers wait for their orders solidar
may have fallen but they say Russia has
lost a large number of men for not much
gain Ed
um
[Music]
highways
this will be the first victory over
Ukrainian forces by Russia after months
of military setbacks
but as Ukraine fortifies its positions
it's unlikely to make much difference to
the outcome of this conflict
and in the fields of dead sunflowers new
trenches are being dug
this war of attrition is brutal and is
seemingly without ends Alex Rossi Sky
News on the outskirts of solidar